Some of the characteristics of services are flexibility. That is,
you are essentially refactoring, if, if you have an existing application, you
want to make that service oriented you factored into, into pieces that then you
could combine in interesting ways. Meaningful here on the slide means each of
the services is something that's meaningful to the end user. They're stateless,
for the reasons described with web services. Stateless means that typically
the code is actually simpler than it would be if you have to remember variables.
And also it's transparent with respect to middleware. Typically,
there's a middleware technology solution that takes your descriptions.
Takes your configuration information and
generates the the, the middle work pieces that need to be generated.